we gonna we gonna do who don't do the
demise of the mere thing well that would
repeat no I mean repetition
okay repetition you know so now just get
grounded all right so okay so what we
don't do is okay I'm gonna start it up
okay I'm gonna say something you repeat
what I say okay okay just stop stop well
you got to do exactly what I'm doing
okay okay I've got to do everything I'm
doing I'll round okay okay t-shirt
t-shirt circle
then we have a going on what you do okay
you gotta follow me okay all right now
jeans jeans you breathin in breathin at
me
racists doubled and raisin stuff
your child let you do okay I follow you
breathe breathe breathe breathe breathe
what what what what what what what what
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
excuse me excuse me excuse me
oh no they did not know you did what you
did all right
I know you did I know you did okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay all right
all right okay okay okay okay all right
all right okay okay okay okay okay then
okay okay then okay
can you bring your voice down a little
bit
oh oh oh
here we go
let it drive you crazy have you ready to
kill somebody sitting across from you I
wanted to chocolate okay now that was a
technique
thank you very much bad thank you thank
you amazing work got to say here's a
pledge it is a pleasure man I hopefully
get to work with you weekend man because
if the camera rolling I'll just stick to
me are you quit suck it up I'm the same
man you just you just you just amazing
man here and awesome doing outstanding
that's all I got to say I'm gonna keep a
hand on my water you juggle some she